dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly if I here in this
series we talked quite a bit about
neural network based learning methods
that are able to generate new images for
us from some sort of sparse description
like a written sentence or a set of
controllable parameters these can enable
us mere mortals without artistic skills
to come up with novel images however one
thing that comes up with almost every
single one of these techniques is the
lack of artistic control you see if we
provide a very coarse input there are
many many different ways for the neural
networks to create photorealistic images
from them so how do we get more control
over these results an earlier paper from
a media generated human faces for us and
used a latent space technique that
allows us some more fine-grained control
over the images it is beyond amazing but
these are called latent variables
because they represent the inner working
process of the neural network and they
do not exactly map to our intuition of
facial features in reality and now have
a look at this new technique that allows
us to edit the geometry of the jawline
of a person put a smile on someone's
face in a more peaceful way than seen in
some Batman movies or remove the
sunglasses and add some crazy hair at
the same time even changing the hair of
someone while adding an earring with a
prescribed shape is also possible whoa
and I just keep talking and talking
about artistic control so it's great
that these shapes are supported but what
about another important aspect of
artistic control for instance colors yep
that is also supported here you can see
that the color of the woman's eyes can
be changed and the technique also
understands the concept of makeup as
well how cool is that not only that but
it is also blazing fast it takes roughly
50 milliseconds to create these images
with the resolution of 512 by 512 so in
short we can do this about 20 times per
second make sure to have a look at the
paper that also contains
section against other techniques and
reference results turns out there is
such a thing as a reference result in
this case which is really cool and you
will also find a novel style loss
formulation that makes all this crazy
wizardry happen
no web app for this one however the
source code is available free of charge
and under a permissive license so let
the experiments begin if you have
enjoyed this video and you feel that a
bunch of these videos are worth three
dollars a month please consider
supporting us on patreon in return
we can offer you early access to these
episodes and more to keep your paper
addiction in check it is truly a
privilege for me to be able to keep
making these videos I am really enjoying
the journey and this is only possible
because of your support on patreon this
is why every episode ends with you
guessed it right
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time